hey 42 here if you've ever been to the
sea
you might have noticed there's an awful
lot of it
oceans cover more than 70 of the earth's
surface
and impact your daily life in ways that
probably never even occurred to you
they regulate the global climate and
drive weather systems
so no matter how far you live from the
coast oceans had some influence
on what you chose to wear today nice
mankini by the way
and look around you no not literally
keep watching me
your life as you know it would be quite
different without marine
transport about 90 percent of the stuff
that's traded around the world
is carried by ships which includes
everything from food
to clothes to furniture and cars even
the fuel in those cars
and the smelly things you hang from the
rear view window
if it weren't for sea travel you
probably wouldn't have the device
you're watching this video on right now
you probably wouldn't even be alive
since oceans are widely regarded as the
birthplace of
life itself so yeah
they're a pretty big deal you would
think we'd know
more about something so important to us
but it seems we're still mostly clueless
about the sea
more than 80 percent of the world's
ocean depths are still
unexplored like oysters they remain a
big
wet salty mystery but the riddles don't
just lie beneath the waves
for as long as humans have been sailing
the high seas
they've been collecting tales about
strange phenomena
like mermaids sirens sea monsters
magical realms and haunted ships
of course most of these stories come
from sex-starved men full of gonorrhea
and rum
so they should probably be taken with a
pinch of sea salt
there is one genuine mystery though
that remains unsolved almost 150 years
after it was discovered
the bizarre account of the ghost ship
mary celeste did you know you can
customize
upgrade and go exploring with your very
own ship
in world of warships who have kindly
sponsored this
video i've been loving playing this game
recently
as a huge history nerd i really
appreciate the realism and historic
accuracy
of the 300 plus ships you can control in
the game
the design of these ships and the
attention to detail
is remarkable such as this weymouth
cruiser based on a real british ship
from the 1910s
that i've been using recently isn't she
a beauty
you can upgrade your ship's weapons and
armor to turn it into an unstoppable
terror of the seas
with your ship you'll explore stunningly
beautiful living landscapes
with weather that changes mid-battle my
favorite part of the game is the online
team battle
against other warship custodians from
around the world
it really keeps me on the edge of my
seat it's a fast-paced struggle to
out-plan and out-maneuver your enemies
and i've just been having a blast with
it
there's never been a better time to jump
into world of warships
because if you register through my link
in the description you'll get an
exclusive starter pack
which includes 200 doubloons two ships
the saint louis
and the premium ship emden 20 restless
fire camouflages
2.5 million credits and seven days of
premium
so don't miss out it was the 4th of
december
1872. in the preceding months
mount vesuvius had erupted in italy the
first ever
fa cup final had been held in england
and some guy had patented dried milk
a week later a meteorite would strike
the earth near a small town called
banbury
but none of this mattered to captain
david morehouse
commander of the canadian ship de gratia
as he stared through his telescope at a
vessel on the horizon
drifting aimlessly in the north atlantic
ocean
morehouse knew the boat it was the mary
celeste
a cargo ship that had left new york
eight days before him
loaded with about 1700 barrels of
denatured alcohol
denatured alcohol isn't like rum it has
an alcohol content between
70 and 99 and is used as a solvent
cleaning agent disinfectant and fuel
drinking it will make you blind or dead
okay maybe it is a bit live room by that
stage in her career the merry celeste
had already accumulated a fair bit of
bad fortune
originally registered under the name the
amazon
her maiden voyage in 1861 from nova
scotia to london
was delayed when just before her
departure
the captain fell ill and died
remember that bit it's important later
then with a new captain the amazon
sailed across the atlantic but collided
with fishing equipment off the coast of
esports maine
before running into and sinking another
ship in the english channel
a few uneventful years passed until
october 1867 when the amazon ran ashore
during a storm
being so badly damaged that her owners
abandoned her as a wreck
the derelict boat was eventually bought
and sold a number of times
before it was restored and renamed
the mary celeste when captain morehouse
founds the ship floating in the open sea
there's a good chance he knew nothing of
her checkered past
but if he had it's safe to say alarm
bells would have been ringing
as he inspected the ship more closely he
noticed she was moving
frantically and that her sails looked
rather odd
he also knew that mary celeste should
have already arrived in italy
so realising something wasn't quite
right the captain changed course to
investigate
when members of the de gracia crew
boarded the mary celeste
they found her deserted but with no
indications of where everyone had gone
or
more importantly why there were no
signs of fire violence or a struggle
the sails were in bad shape some missing
altogether
and the rigging and that's what land
lovers like us call a system of ropes
which hold a sailing ship's masts in
place
was damaged and hanging out of place the
main hatch which is the big hole in the
middle of the deck where you load and
unload
cargo still had its cover on but the
covers of the hatches at the front and
back of the boat
fore and aft in sailing terms were off
and lying besides the hatches on the
deck the cargo of industrial alcohol was
untouched
which ruled out pirates or blind
alcoholics
as an obvious cause about three and a
half feet of water sloshed around the
cargo hold
which was a significant amount but not
alarming
someone had disassembled one of the two
pumps but the vessel was still perfectly
sea worthy
the only thing of importance missing was
the lifeboat
well latin all the people obviously the
crew's belongings were still in their
quarters
and there was enough food and water on
board to last another six
months most of the ship's papers were
missing along with the captain's
navigational instruments
and in the mate's cabin was the ship's
log book with its final entry
dated at 8am on the 25th of november
10 days earlier the final logbook entry
placed the mary celeste
within sight of santa maria island in
the azores
a group of nine small volcanic islands
in the middle
of nautical nowhere by the time
morehouse and his crew discovered her
she had drifted almost 750 kilometers to
the east
10 people were missing from the mary
celeste
including captain benjamin spooner
briggs his wife
sarah the couple's two-year-old daughter
sofia
and seven crewmen none of them
were ever seen or heard from again
briggs was part owner of the boat and an
extremely experienced skipper
he hand-picked his own crew and they
were all regarded as first-class sailors
overall a crack team and not the type 2
abandoned ship without a serious reason
so what was that reason why
and how did 10 people disappear
from the mary celeste without a trace
these questions would soon fill
newspapers and books across the globe
but first they appeared in the lower
courts of gibraltar
after finding the mary celeste captain
morehouse decided to
sail her to gibraltar about 1 100
kilometers away
so he could claim salvage the law of
salvage is an ancient part of
international maritime law
that says anyone who helps rescue or
recover a ship or cargo
is owed a reward proportional to its
value
by the ship's owner in this case
morehouse and the crew of the de gracia
had rescued the mary celeste and sailed
her back to safety at their own risk
when the ship arrived in gibraltar she
was confiscated by the authorities until
the salvage hearings could be resolved
in court
as part of those court proceedings it
was suggested the disappearance of
captain briggs
his family and his crew were down to
foul play
marks were found on the bow of the ship
that some claimed were made by an axe
there was also dark stains found both on
the boat
and on the captain's sword that might
have been blood
the attorney general in gibraltar
believed the crew got drunk one night on
the alcohol in the ship's hold
even though it was undrinkable and
slaughtered captain briggs and his
family in a drunken frenzy
before escaping in the lifeboat just a
regular friday night then
but soon the results of scientific tests
proved nothing dodgy had happened aboard
the mary celeste
and after three months the authorities
released a ship from custody
captain morehouse and his crew received
less than eight thousand dollars for
their salvage efforts
which was well below the expected
pavement given the value of the ship and
its cargo
unfortunately for morehouse the court
case had generated rumors that he and
his men
had killed the occupants of the mary
celeste so they could claim the ship for
salvage
that accusation wasn't ever proved but
the doubts
never quite faded and by awarding such a
small salvage settlement
it seems the court also remains
suspicious
other theories of foul play have briggs
and morehouse as friends
conspiring to claim the insurance money
for the ship
and staging a disappearance another
admittedly somewhat ridiculous view was
that captain briggs who was a devout
christian
had lost his mind in a religious frenzy
and murdered everyone on board before
killing himself
just a regular sunday then in the
decades that followed the story of the
mary celeste was retold and exaggerated
many times over in 1883 the los angeles
times published a false narrative
in which the ship was found in perfect
condition and fully rigged
the cooking fire was burning in the
galley stove
dinner was on the table barely cold and
the lug book was updated to the hour
before the ship was found
the next year arthur conan doyle the man
who would later become the author
of sherlock holmes wrote a short story
based on the mary celeste
it was a fictional piece but as with the
la times story
much of it became accepted as fact these
kinds of fabrications have made it even
harder to come up with
plausible explanations for what happened
aboard captain briggs's ship
but a few proposals have gained
popularity over the years
let's get the first and most obvious one
out of the way
briggs his family and his crew were
whisked away
by aliens since aliens are apparently
responsible for
building the pyramids making crop
circles assassinating jfk
and impregnating my neighbor janet i
suppose we should at least consider the
possibility
that they swooped down on a random ship
in the middle of the sea
and kidnapped all of those on board
because aliens obviously have nothing
better to do with their time
another guess is that the mary celeste
was hit by a water spout
the oceanic equivalent of a tornado
which would explain all the water in the
ship's hold
a water spout would also have caused the
atmospheric temperature to drop
which could have driven water from the
bilges the bottom part of the ship where
all the gunk collects
up into the pumps this might have
convinced the crew the vessel had taken
on more water than she actually had
and was therefore in danger of sinking
under such circumstances briggs might
have chosen to abandon ship
whilst he was still in sight of land
building on the theme of natural
disasters
other commentators have theorized an
earthquake on the seabed
imaginatively known as a seaquake which
may have generated enough turbulence
aboard the mary's celeste
to cause the spillage of alcohol and the
release of alcohol fumes
that would potentially explain the
hatches which might have been opened up
in an attempt to air the cargo hold
it would also tie in with the nine empty
barrels that were found on board
if there had been a build up of fumes
briggs would have been concerned
and that concern may have been elevated
by rumblings from the cargo hold
the smell of fumes perhaps even an
explosion
in that case briggs and his crew might
have climbed into the lifeboat
attached it to the ship and allowed
themselves to float behind it at a
distance
that might seem like a reasonable enough
response to the situation
but one has to question the sense in
tying yourself to something
you think might be about to explode
especially
since a lifeboat in the open ocean is
far from a safe place to be
next time you go swimming throw a cork
into the pool
and then do your best cannonball that'll
give you
some idea of what a small lifeboat might
face
in the open ocean all it would have
taken was for the tow line to come loose
or snap
and the ship's occupants would have been
in serious trouble
some experts suggest that mary celeste
would have been a safer bet than the
lifeboat
even if she had suffered an explosion
and that briggs would have been a fool
to abandon ship
but the alcohol explosion view of events
had a lot of support at the time
and gained some credibility from later
reports of ships whose cargo
had exploded under similar conditions
it was also noted the nine empty barrels
were made of red
oak unlike the other barrels which were
made
of white oak red oak is more porous than
white oak
and it's possible some of the alcohol
may have seeped out of the barrels
filling the cargo hold with more toxic
fumes than the last time you farted
under the duvet
the main argument against the idea that
the mary's celeste crew were trying to
escape an explosion
was that no scorch marks or evidence of
an explosion were ever found
which is quite important when suspecting
an explosion
but in 2006 an experiment carried out by
dr
andre seller of university college
london showed that such an outcome
was perfectly possible seller built a
replica of the mary's celeste's hold
with paper cubes to represent barrels
and then use butane to generate the type
of explosion
that would have happened had alcohol
fumes in the holes
ignited the results showed a massive
explosion
with no burning no scorching and no sots
left behind
according to cella the trapped gas
created a pressure wave type of
explosion
with a spectacular surge of flame
followed by relatively cool air
such an explosion would have been enough
to blow open the hatches
and have everyone fleeing the ship like
well
rats fleeing a sinking ship too many
an alcohol-fueled explosion and a
desperate evacuation
is the most logical and scientifically
sound explanation
of what happened to those aboard the
mary celeste
but forensic researcher anne mcgregor
thinks there's more to the story after
cross-referencing
notes from the salvage trial with the
ship's log
and oceanic data from the time mcgregor
concluded
briggs instruments were probably damaged
because his measurements appeared to be
wrong
he was actually 120 nautical miles west
of where he thought he was it seems the
ship had experienced lousy weather the
night before the final logbook recording
and with the pumps broken perhaps due to
coal dust buildup from a previous cargo
the crew had no way to measure how much
water had been taken on in the rough
seas
if briggs suspected there was too much
water on board
he would have had a decision to make if
he pressed on he knew there wouldn't be
land for hundreds of miles
so if there was a possibility the ship
was sinking
their best chance would be to head for
santa maria island
which by his faulty calculations was
nearby
whilst they still could that might not
have been the best decision
but it also wouldn't have been crazy one
issue
with many of these theories is that
captain briggs not only abandoned his
ship
he also abandoned his logbook if he
really did think the ship was slowly
sinking
he would still have had plenty of time
to collect a log or at least to scribble
a quick note as to his plans
ship's captains in the 19th century were
not in the business of forgetting to
make crucial entries in their logbooks
no matter the circumstances of course
we'll never know for sure what happened
to those on board the mary celeste
but we do know the ship's bad run
continued long after the mysterious
disappearance of her crew
when the trial in gibraltar was
concluded she sailed to italy as
originally planned
to deliver her cargo before heading to
new york
but by the time the mary celeste arrived
in the big apple
the rumors of bloodshed murder mutiny
and inexplicable disappearances
had circulated throughout the shipping
world and nobody wanted anything to do
with
her eventually the owners were forced to
sell her at a considerable loss
the new owners didn't fare much better
with the ship consistently losing money
and in 1879 she called in at saint
helena bay to seek medical help
when the captain fell sick he died on
the island
shortly after in a sequence of events
eerily similar to the way in which the
ship's first captain had died
i told you that it was important all
told the mary celeste
had seen three captains die prematurely
fueling speculations that the ship was
cursed
six years later luck still hadn't
improved and the desperate skipper
a captain parker conspired with a group
of shippers in a crooked plot to finally
make some cash
on what had been a truly terrible
investment
they filled the mary celeste with
worthless cargo which they insured for
thirty thousand dollars
about eight hundred and fifty thousand
dollars in today's money
before deliberately running the vessel
of grounds near haiti
wrecking her forever investigations by
the insurance company
revealed the attempted trickery and
captain parker and his accomplices
were soon facing trial in boston for
conspiracy to commit insurance fraud
parker was also charged with willfully
casting away a ship
a crime known as baratrip that used to
be punishable by death
luckily for the captain he avoided the
death penalty and the jury was split on
the crime of fraud
so parker went free but his reputation
was ruined and he died in poverty just
three months later
one of his fellow defendants went mad
and another killed himself
even under normal circumstances this
would be an almost unbelievable chain of
events
but looking back it seems very little
was normal about the mary celeste
or those who came into contact with her
perhaps it's for the best
she now lies in a permanent watery grave
at the bottom of the ocean
thanks for watching and thanks again to
world of warships for sponsoring this
video
don't forget to check them out using the
link below